hey GQ it's Kim Kardashian and today
we're going to go undercover on the
Internet it's actually
[Music]
me let's check
Twitter okay is Kim Kardashian going on
dates these days asking for a friend I
don't know I don't know I I wouldn't
answer that here do you have a number
one green flag a number one green flag
and if it doesn't go down like this it's
my ultimate red flag is just how someone
treats everyone around them you know a
waiter or just whoever's around I really
pay attention to how people treat other
people next loved this podcast KK what
makes you so passionate about prison
reform you know I started off just
feeling like something was as simple as
just being unfair and I didn't know much
about the system and I'm always someone
that likes to learn and grow once I
started to really figure out how messed
up our system is I really wanted to do
everything that I can to help I love
doing this podcast because I was able to
really like amplify the issues in our
system and I will continue to do that
for
sure
Instagram chaotic bottoms says North has
such great style where is she pulling
her pieces from I never thought that at
10 years old my daughter would already
be stealing my clothes she really has
the best style and she loves to go
vintage shopping she pulls a lot from my
closet and from her dad's closet I
didn't pull anything from my mom's
closet actually but what Courtney and I
did this is so mean she walked in once
and we were like putting our names on
her shoes and she's like what are you
guys doing and we're like well when you
die we'll know like who gets what she
was like 30 but it's crazy that North
gets it so young and just picks out the
coolest stuff that I have posted Serena
Williams literally not how you hold a
racket clearly I have to give you
lessons LOL hard eyes first of all it
was walking to the other side is there a
special way you have to hold a racket
just to walk from one side to the other
side I was also out of Bounds at that
point but I'm waiting I would love
lessons from the goat this video of me
wake surfing it says at this point I
feel like you're the sports girl of the
family
I think the one thing people don't
really get from me is I'm an athlete
like I actually am such a good athlete
and people that come on trips with me
people that are around that might not
know this get really surprised I'm just
like adventurous and I like to do Sports
I don't know why it's so shocking to
people when they see that from me or I
post about it that's like how I grew up
and then someone else asked H this gets
so old did you find your earring while
you were at it anytime I'm in water
people will ask me if I found my diamond
earring in the ocean I don't know if I
showed this on our show but Kylie found
the earring so she dove in the ocean put
on goggles found it and then she went
back and found the back of it that's how
clear the water is in Bora Bora so guys
the earring has been found it was found
in 2010 if anyone's going to Bora Bora
searching for gold and diamonds not
there what's the best trait you got from
your dad trait would maybe be his work
ethic just the habit of taking us to
school every day and then going to the
office and just seeing how hard he
worked but I think I would always
remember things that he would say and he
made it so clear that blood is thicker
than water that was his thing and family
over everything so I think just the way
he lived his life with his family and my
grandparents and his siblings like
everyone was so close and they'd hang
out all weekend they genuinely were all
best friends and really loved each other
and that's how my family is he would
teach us all of these Armenian words and
now my kids say all of those words and I
love bringing my kids to Armenia just
all the things my dad talked about and
wished he could have done I feel so
lucky that I get to do them with my kids
even though he never got the chance to
do them next okay Tik
Tok when do you give it to them
beautiful idea so I write my kids every
year for their birthday a four or five
Page Letter detailing the year I started
off with their nickname I talk about
everything the funny words they're
saying and then they get deep I just
want them to know that if I weren't here
every question they've ever had would be
answered in these letters my dad wrote
me one and my mom wrote me one when I
was going into high school and I wished
I had more and so I do them for each of
my kids' birthdays so I can't wait to
give this to when the cool question was
okay stop rambling when will you give it
to them um I don't know should I stop at
8: 18 should I stop at 21 I don't know
help me decide guys is this on Tik Tok
can we do a Twitter poll 18 or 21 Kim so
gorgeous a thank you how do you define
your personal style I think personal
style has different moods and feelings
and so sometimes I'm super glammed up
and I feel like one way and then
sometimes I can just be like really
simple and Casual when I'm at home and I
never could figure out what that was cuz
I was always so so dressed up like super
Glitz and Glam or horrendous sweats and
pajamas and that's kind of one of the
reasons I launched our skims Lounge
stuff is just I needed that chill in
between simple casual style so I have
different sides to my personality I
wonder what it's like for her to be a
soccer mom and taking her son to games
as saint but I think it's probably so
awesome I've learned to love
this sport so much I like to take each
one of my kids on a special trip with
their friends and what they want to do
to wherever they want to go and so I've
Loved starting this soccer mom tour with
all my besties and their sons who are
besties with my sons it's just been such
an amazing bonding experience so I love
that he's into soccer it could be
wrestling and it could be awful I was in
Italy and I See earling Holland and I
freak the out because I know my son
would be so excited you know it's like
his thing so I'm like such a loser
FaceTiming at this event being like sa
you'll never guess who I ran into and
I'm like FaceTiming him and I'm like
what I've turned into this person I've
turned into this person that like it's
I'm sorry my son is everything Cristiano
Ronaldo we're definitely inner Miami
fans we had so much fun at PSG every
Stadium's so different Arsenal
everyone's been so good I don't know
every team I'm not going to pick I'm not
going to pick a team just yet yeah I'm a
soccer mom on to
Wikipedia after totaling her car at age
16 already not true her father agreed to
buy her a new one on condition that
absolutely not true on condition that
she agreed to be responsible for paying
all expenses related to any future
damages no so the story is before I got
a car my dad was an attorney made me
sign a contract with him that before I
received the car I had to obviously take
care of any expenses related to damaging
it I had to make sure it was washed once
a week it was fully taken care of it
says she subsequently began working at
body a local clothing store in Ino
California which she worked at for 4
years and I assisted in opening the
Calabasas location so I did hit my car
pretty lightly didn't total it but I
needed to fix the scratch so I got a job
working at a clothing store the coolest
clothing store in the valley that
actually sparked my love for dolang
Gonic I would have to like unpack the
clothes and hang everything and price
them and steam them and so every time
the Dolce box came I was in
heaven in 2006 Kim began working as a
stylist for Paris Hilton that's not true
I organized her closet but I was not a
stylist so I didn't put outfits together
for her I didn't pick them out or shop
I just organized what she had and she
had a lot of stuff a childhood friend of
hers yes that part's true our moms were
always really close when we were little
we went to preschool together actually
it said she appeared in several episodes
of the reality series the simple life I
don't know if I
did I might have been like with her in
the background just while she was
filming I wasn't like in it and was
frequently photographed accompanying
Hilton to events and parties I will
always say when we did start hanging out
in our 20s I learned so much from her
just like her grace like she's the
nicest person she knows how to have the
most fun they have the best stories the
best memories the best photos Us in
Australian putting on disguises hiding
under blankets like sneaking out just to
go have a normal dinner so I I credit
her a lot to putting me on and also
seeing a lot from her and how she lives
her life love you p
kaora is that a
thing who's the smartest Kardashian
sister you know they always ask us to do
these rankings and I've decided I'm not
doing those because I think people are
trying to like pit us against each other
and to get a little sound bite so we are
all equally as
smart what does Kim Kardashian do for
fun lay in bed eat mint Oreo ice cream
watch love is blind and not talk to
anybody posted all right let's see some
YouTube
[Music]
comments are we not going to talk about
North's painting abilities what the heck
she's so talented I thought the
landscape was a prank yeah I I got into
it with people on the internet about
this because everyone said it was fake
even I posted a sunset she just did and
she's been painting for years and she
loves it and she has an amazing art
teacher she's talented and it's not like
the craziest concept she definitely
didn't get it from me I will say that
she did a sunrise and a sunset I just
hung them in my house and I can't wait
for her to come home and see where
they're hung
[Music]
Reddit I wonder how Kim in 2023 would
restyle her honestly I'd wear the
glasses I'm into the Hoops the rest has
got to go like what was I thinking and I
thought I was killing it that's the
funny part it's all about Evolution if I
was always so stylish there would be no
room to grow I just love different eras
different fun moments this one's
humiliating but do you baby
girl okay guys that's it I'm signing off
the
internet